vamos a trabajar con la sucesión
geométrica siguiente y yo lo que quiero
llegar es a una serie geométrica pero
antes de eso trabajemos con una sucesión
geométrica la cual va a empezar en 1 y
va a tener una razón de un medio por lo
tanto voy a tener 1 por un medio lo cual
me va a dar un medio en el segundo
término después un medio por un medio lo
cual me da un cuarto después un cuarto
por un medio lo cual me da un octavo y
así y seguimos seguimos seguimos porque
es una sucesión infinita y bueno si yo
quisiera expresar esta sucesión de la
siguiente manera me quedaría como la
sucesión de los términos a n
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito con la
siguiente regla de correspondencia y
como es una sucesión geométrica entonces
el término n lo sacamos con el término
inicial en este caso es uno que va a
multiplicar a la razón la razón es un
medio entonces uno por un medio elevado
a la n 1 y esto lo puedes verificar
porque este 1 lo podemos ver como un
medio elevador a 0 este es un medio lo
podemos ver como un medio elevado a la
primera potencia y de hecho lo voy a
poner aquí este un cuarto lo mismo que
un medio elevado al cuadrado
y siguen y si te das cuenta en el
término 1 estamos elevando la potencia 0
en el término 2 a la potencia 1 en el
término 3 en la potencia 2 y por lo
tanto se cumple que la potencia es n
menos uno y por lo tanto me queda que
esto es igual a un medio elevado a la
n-1 muy bien pero lo que quiero en este
vídeo no es la sucesión geométrica sino
la serie' geométrica es decir me quiero
tomar la suma de todos estos términos y
lo voy a poner aquí la suma de uno más
un medio más un cuarto más un octavo más
así hasta el infinito y bueno esto es lo
que se le conoce como una serie
geométrica y esto es muy importante así
que déjenme apuntarlo aquí arriba cuando
hablo de una suma de una sucesión
geométrica me estoy tomando una serie
geométrica esta de aquí es una serie de
geométrica y cómo se denota bueno cuando
hablamos de una serie geométrica lo
ponemos de la siguiente manera y déjeme
escribirlo para acá esto va a ser igual
a sigma es decir este es el símbolo que
denota una suma infinita y déjenme
hablar un poco para que la pantalla para
que se vea
asignan o también se le conoce como la
suma desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito de
la siguiente sucesión de la sucesión de
los términos a n
pero a n es igual a un medio elevado de
la potencia n menos uno es decir esta
expresión está diciendo que me voy a
tomar la suma de un medio de acero que
es uno más un medio elevado a la 1 que
es un medio más un medio elevado al
cuadrado que es un cuarto más etcétera
etcétera etcétera y bien lo que quiero
ver en este vídeo es que te quede muy
clara cuál es la diferencia entre una
sucesión geométrica y una serie
geométrica y en los siguientes vídeos
voy a hablar más de series y también de
cómo puedo resolverlas y llegar a un
valor final